ma personne ma l'es13 nyn's 3000 à la
ola holla holla holla holla là que du
lourd que du work que des travaux est
magnifique
j'aime bien celle évasif je peux voir
une par mi-temps 0-1 ouais je les
intéressés font rêver sur sable sur
trois mois je vois de quoi qu'en ait été
pour l'instant voilà jacques comme ça ça
me dérange pas outre mesure mais un de
mes rêves
maintenant je le dis maintenant elle
mais motus et bouche cousue motus et
bouche cousue je passe la porte d'ici
les shérifs dans l'émission d'hier
[Musique]
attention ça pique un à la la ça pique
il est beau le plus les très bons c'est
vintage sexuelle adore son mât livre je
suis très fan de plus à l'abri dans la
société
c'est ma femme la porte au nez du caji
mien c'est qu'à celui des françoises
il a adressé le avons des gens qui
l'avaient aidé à fonder jour je dois
faire rêver commence unis la tête
d'après son coeur et dans 5 minutes tu
m'appelles bouffard ils croient qu'on a
pas trace de [ __ ] et est-ce que vous
avez remarqué la marque a quitté c'est
qu'on l'appelle il fait les samedis des
côtes est et oui même façon le prime a
le bras il a brossé ou ses magouilles
alors oui ça fait pas attention et je le
connais valeur perd soliste jusqu'à 100
4e temps
[Musique]
il ya une vraie attente c'est vrai on
sent maintenant à la nation ne semblait
pas dans son attention
bref pas franchement je vous dire la
vérité je trouve qu'on l'a tapé fort
fort et juste les kalou et les audiences
voisins et make the guardian lui j'ai
des gros clowns au fait les gros zozos
ce soir je veux tout le monde geo tous
les plus grands créateurs de ces câbles
à cavani ya michou sur le live en quoi
me chambrait parce qu'ils étaient tous
très beaux grèce et michou mes frères
comment tu me touches quoi tu kiffes les
choux j'aime beaucoup en temps tu veux
je me relève mes cheveux tatouages suit
la hâte en séries il peut être la toile
celui-là non mais c est dans attentats
en série pour michaud pour mieux vous
pouvez pas pour michaud est ce que tu
vas faire et je suis posée dans le club
normal dans mes mais fier mais fier
sinon mille club